[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe une
émission enregistrée une nouvelle fois
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles
notre invité pour cette émission et
pervenche berès eurodéputés socialistes
d'île de france
ensemble nous évoquons principalement
les réformes envisagées pour la zone
euro les principaux leaders européens et
nationaux semblent vouloir bouger sur la
question fera pas vers plus de
fédéralisme de quatre outils la zone
euro peut-elle se doter à court terme
nous poserons la question à notre invité
et puis comme à chaque émission nous
vous présenterons un père fondateur de
l'union européenne aujourd'hui retour
sur le parcours de valéry giscard
d'estaing et il sera question également
d'amis culture à quelques jours du début
du salon international à paris nous
verrons le poids de l'agriculture chez
nos voisins c'est en fin d'émission
[Musique]
pervenche berès bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes eurodéputés socialistes depuis 1994
vous êtes ici une historique spécialiste
reconnu de l'union européenne et de ses
thématiques
vous êtes membre du ps depuis 1982 juste
après l'élection de françois mitterrand
vous avez été aussi conseillère
municipale à 16 dans les hauts-de-seine
entre 2001 et 2008
mais on comprend bien que votre amour à
vous c'est l'europe alors savez-vous
déjà si vous serez candidate à un
sixième mandat en 2019 ce que vous
réfléchissez déjà la question je réponds
pas à cette question
c'est pas la priorité aujourd'hui pour
vous il ya l'histoire j'en parlais
justement l'introduction avec vous qui
êtes là depuis 1994 chaque mois tv 78
vous fait découvrir celles et ceux qui
ont participé à la construction
européenne
ce mois ci valéry giscard d'estaing il
fut le plus jeune président élu c'était
en 1974 il avait alors 48 ans on retient
aussi de lui son engagement en faveur de
l'europe
son parcours avec philippe le guen
directeur de l'association jean monnet
basée à bazoches sur guyonne dans les
yvelines
[Musique]
avant même d'être élu président de la
république valéry giscard d'estaing
avait une vision
engagé européenne ilna
il a été très tôt
lire impressionné par le projet de
première construction européenne et qui
l'avait soutenu il avait défendu le
traité de rome même au sein de son
propre parti à l'époque
et puis bien écouter quand il a été élu
plutôt président de la république en
c'est une époque charnière importante
pour l'europe puisque c'est l'époque où
on a commencé à s'intéresser aux à la
fin un système monétaire européen qui
devait préfigurer le la monnaie unique
nous avons aujourd'hui c'est une époque
où on a aussi commencé à parler de
certains élargissement de l'europe
et puis on était dans une époque encore
de guerre froide et valéry giscard
d'estaing a tout de suite compris aussi
l'importance de continuer à faire
travailler le couple franco allemand
comme moteur de la construction
européenne par la suite quand le
président giscard d'estaing n'était plus
président il a continué à oeuvrer pour
la construction européenne la convention
s'achève aujourd'hui
joe résultat est de proposer la première
constitution pour l'europe qui
malheureusement n'a pas vu le jour en
totalité puisque vous le savez en 2005
un référendum d'abord en france puis en
boeing ba a rejeté un ce traité on a vu
d'abord que l'opinion à peu se détacher
du projet européen et elle s'en
détachaient parce qu'elle voyait plus
objectif
elle a vu l'objectif au début parce que
c'est la paire devant l'objectif
puis peu à peu le système est devenu
opaque était une bureaucratie ou perçu
glauque racines on ne voyait pas très
bien quels étaient les objectifs que
c'était pour faire quoi
souvent on a reproché au traité
constitutionnel ne pas avoir été
démocratique pourtant cette convention
représentait absolument toutes les
sensibilités tous les partis politiques
et la société civile
mais elle a peut-être pas bénéficié
d'autant de publicité quelle heure de
communication qu'elle aurait souhaité
[Musique]
pervenche berès selon selon mes
informations vous connaissez d'ancien
président de la république vous avez je
crois travail et ont collaboré avec lui
quel souvenir vous vous gardez de ce
travail avec valéry giscard d'estaing de
l'homme et du travail peut-être travail
très intense puisque je dis toujours
lorsque je retrace mon parcours que je
lui dois beaucoup
il est devenu président de la commission
des affaires étrangères à un moment où
j'étais administrateur de l'assemblée
nationale et lorsqu'il est il a commencé
à prier la commission des affaires
étrangères
moi j'étais très vous engagez déjà comme
socialiste et il ya eu un moment où je
pensais que ça devenait compliqué de
travailler avec ce président là et j'ai
commencé à travailler pour danielle
mitterrand qui organisait le 40e
anniversaire de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme et un
moment où l'événement s'approchaient
j'avais besoin de davantage de temps
pour j'ai demandé au président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
valéry giscard d'estaing
si je peux travailler à mi temps et il
me l'a refusé donc il m'a obligé à
franchir le pas et à passer de l'autre
côté et à rejoindre et à rejoindre le
cabinet de laurent fabius pour pouvoir
le faire
et puis ensuite je les retrouvais en
tant que président de la convention ici
et là nous avons eu des échanges très
intense toujours intellectuellement très
stimulant c'était il ya quelques années
alors au tour à l'actualité la plus
chaude celle du moment à commencer par
l'union européenne qui réduit déjà de
moitié sa liste noire des paradis
fiscaux liste établie seulement au début
décembre dans la foulée des paradise
peppers on se rappelle les huit pays
retirer passe désormais en liste grise
en sorte de salles d'attentes si je puis
dire quelle est votre réaction après ce
revirement seulement un peu plus d'un
mois après cette liste noire
il n'a pas échappé que dans ces pays qui
passe de la liste noire à la liste grise
le premier d'entre eux c'est pas dans
marque donc c'est dire la difficulté est
d'abord d'établir ces listes chacun le
savait avant le début de l'exercice mais
les sous il n'y avait pas de pays de
l'union européenne déjà il ya déjà ça
c'est que certains pays ont des
pratiques tous peut-être mais d'autres
plus que mais c'est samedi toute la
difficulté de ce combat mais c'est la
responsabilité du conseil puisque sa
part une initiative de la commission
européenne de d'amputer ainsi la liste
c'est bien le résultat d'une négociation
diplomatique au sein du coup c'est quoi
ce que j'observe tout de même c'est que
pour nous tous est totalement opaque
aussi à des bonnes raisons balafon nous
le dira oui cela m'a été dévoilé je
connais pas les bonnes raisons pour
retirer ces pays de la liste et puis ici
on les met sur la liste grise à l'as moi
je veux être sûr mais qu'on se donne les
moyens de vérifier afin qu'on soit aussi
dur avec eux qu'on l'a été avec la grèce
pour vérifier qu'ils mettaient en place
des réformes et j'ai pas l'impression
qu'on ait négocié avec eux des
memorandum of understanding comme on a
fait avec la grèce pour être sûr que par
rapport il s'engage il faut
effectivement ce qu'ils ont dit ce
qu'ils allaient faire
excusez moi mais pourquoi ces duos pour
l'union européenne de 2,2 vouloir
pointer du doigt par exemple le panama
en quoi le panama est un est un poids
économique important à ce point là pour
les enjeux de l'union européenne est ce
que ce sont pas des hommes plutôt qu'ils
ont des intérêts je dis ça sans preuves
évidemment mais ça paraît bizarre pour
un citoyen peut-être deuxième je vous
remercie d'exclure que des femmes
puissent être utilisés au panama mais
plus que des personnes physiques je
crains que ce soit des personnes morales
qui est cet intérêt donc la question
c'est par le territoire du pad amara qui
est en cause c'est la façon dont ce
territoire sert de boîte aux lettres à
des entreprises qui n'ont aucune réalité
économique
c'est un principe qui est aujourd'hui
beaucoup avancé parce que quand dans le
domaine bancaire
on avance avec des grosses législation
et donc nous disent ah il faut appliquer
un principe de proportionnalité donc ce
qu'on pouvait demander des gros il faut
pas le demander pour nous j'appliquerai
bien volontiers le même principe au
territoire de panama panama ce petit
territoire et ils adaptés à la
localisation du chiffre d'affaires aussi
important que ce que manifestement que
ce qui manifestement s'y déroule moins
d'opacité plus plus de transparence
c'est évidemment aussi en lien avec les
réformes qui pourraient toucher la zone
euro d'ici quelques mois le thème qui va
nous intéresser a à présent vous êtes
membre vous ici au parlement européen de
la puissante commission en charge des
affaires économiques et monétaires vous
connaissez bien évidemment ces sujets
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
est presque dans un moment historique il
ya une fenêtre de tir peut être qu'on
n'a pas vu depuis très longtemps très
longtemps le chômage qui baisse le
retour de la croissance un président
français très enclin sur ces questions
là aussi une coalition un monde enfin
qui se forment favorable aussi à bouger
sur ces sujets là est ce que vous êtes
optimiste et on va pouvoir bouger sur
des réformes pour la zone euro enfin
c'est en tout cas le prisme de la
volonté
la fenêtre d'opportunité llc présentait
plusieurs fois
même ces dernières années même ces
dernières années où il ya eu des moments
où on pensait que c'était
c'était le bon moment pour faire les
choses et à chaque fois on a raté
l'occasion
j'espère bien que cette fois ci on va
pas la rater d'autant plus que ce qui
est vrai c'est que je vois que du côté
allemand wolfgang schaeuble n'est plus
en responsabilité l'ancien ministre des
finances
j'ai désormais président du bundestag
président du bundestag qui était à la
fois très européen c'est vrai qu'il a
été très européen fait traduire aussi on
a préféré conservateur d'une certaine
manière avec une conception très
juridique de la monnaie il fallait
appliquer les règles même si les règles
n'étaient pas bonnes
et c'était un horizon indépassable or
aujourd'hui je constate qu en allemagne
là aussi il ya une grande coalition qui
arrivent à se mettre en place elle se
fera sur la base d'un spd qui est très
déterminé à peser sur ces questions là
et ça c'est ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
ce qui veut dire que l'allemagne malgré
tout à reste le principal moteur là
dedans on parle souvent du moteur
franco-allemand j'ai l'impression que
vous écoutez que finalement c'est
surtout en guerre la marcal qui aura le
dernier mot qui pourra placer ses voeux
l'orage qui a un pouvoir de blocage
meilleur on a besoin des deux il faut à
la fois que
le couple franco allemand est là sa
dynamique alors je sais pas si c'est oui
l'homme et oui la femme
mais ce que je sais c'est que il ya une
répartition presque historique des rôles
à et si là il ya un équilibrage quand
même vous pensez en ce moment entre la
france et l'allemagne pendant longtemps
on a dit que la france suivait les idées
les projets allemands est ce
qu'aujourd'hui quand emmanuel mahout g
notamment les idées pour la zone euro
des menus de mac - qu'il a présentée en
septembre pour faire l'étude emmanuel
macron moi je suis beaucoup écouté son
discours à la fois athènes et à la
sorbonne septembre mais tout ça pour
l'instant a besoin d'être déclinées dans
des propositions plus concrètes parce
que il ya un enthousiasme il ya une
campagne qui s'est fait sur la
thématique européenne
mais derrière maintenant il va falloir
rentrer sur des propositions concrètes
et comme vous le savez le diable et
parfois dans les détails
alors on va essayer d'être précis pas
trop technique pour ceux qui nous
regardent
il ya plusieurs chantiers qui sont
évoqués dans la presse ici au parlement
on entend parler d'un fonds monétaire
européen à l'instar du fmi un budget
spécial de la zone euro un super
ministre aussi des finances de la zone
euro avant nous expliquer à chaque fois
en quoi cela consiste-t-il
dites nous quel est le principal
chantier aujourd'hui selon vous c'est
peut-être un autre chantier que j'ai pas
évoqué oui c'est ajouté qu'il n'avait
pas évoqué mais voilà ils sont tous
aussi importants et justement parce
qu'ils ne se feront pas tous en même
temps où c'est bien c'est long comme pro
saison
mais sauf que on est un moment où on a
quand même appris que sur une question
comme ça
lorsqu'on fait qu'un tout petit bout et
bien du coup reste au milieu du guet on
fragilise quelque chose qu'on a voulu
construire et du coup on s'expose à
beaucoup de risques et je ne veux pas
qu'on soit au milieu du gué très fort
très loin il faut avoir une vision comme
quand on a fait l'euro quand on a fait
l'euro on n'a pas fait tout premiers
jours mais on le savait où on allait
voilà on avait une feuille de route
c'est ça il fait de retirer ans et où on
va on a des rendez vous des étapes excès
là on a besoin de la même chose on fera
pas tout en un jour mais si on n'a pas
une vision globale
ça va pas marcher donc le champ 606
pâles selon vous le chantier principal
c'est d'achever leur hausse est à un
gros chantier 1 et je vais le
fonctionnement de la zone euro ça
suppose que lorsqu'il ya un show il faut
avoir un outil que cet outil
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a appelé le
mécanisme européen de stabilité
certains veulent le transformer en un
fonds monétaire européen
parce que comme ça ça permettrait de ne
plus avoir le fmi qui vient s'occuper de
nos affaires mais la conception qu'on a
du fmi comme un espèce de super gendarme
ne me convient pas moi je pense que nous
avons besoin davantage d'un budget de la
zone euro pour amortir les chocs
lorsqu'il y en a pour stimuler
l'investissement
sachez que dans le pacte de stabilité
personne ne dit que la politique
économique de la zone euro doit
surveiller son niveau d'investissement
et puis dernier gros chantier c'est
celui de la convergence entre les états
membres
vous ne pouvez pas avoir une monnaie
unique et des états qui divergent
complètement donc la question de savoir
ce soit très très long terme ça une
convergence de toutes les économies
européennes déjà si vous vous occupez de
savoir comment est ce que les pays
flottent en termes de taux d'imposition
sur les sociétés ou de salaire minimum
c'est des outils de convergence qui veut
aller plus ou moins vite mais c'est pas
du très très long terme pour venir sur
ce fonds monétaire européen par exemple
puisque c'est probablement un terme qui
parle aux gens on a beaucoup entendu
parler du fmi ces dernières années
notamment avec la grèce
du coup ce fonds monétaire européen
selon vous ne devrez pas servir par
juste à soutenir un pays en cas en cas
de choc qui doit lui permettre aussi par
exemple d'investir sur sur des projets
d'avenir encadrant cas de coup dur
c'est pas juste pour remettre l'économie
à flot c'est aussi pour re voir plus
loin
regardez bien ce dont on parle l'union
européenne ça n'est pas la planète donc
le fmi ça a été créé pour une planète
avec un organe extérieur qui intervient
qu impose ses règles dans un pays en
difficulté dans l'union européenne on
n'est pas dans ce cas de figure 1
alors ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on dit
puisqu'on veut pas que le fmi
intervienne il faut avoir un effet me
soit mais c'est ça ne passait pour que
ce soit le petit frère du fmi vous dit
d'abord ne sert à rien d'abord je ne
peux pas un
et ensuite c'est pas le coeur du
problème le coeur du problème c'est de
savoir comment est-ce que effectivement
celui d'arrêter s'organise que moi
est-ce que encore une fois on permet le
maintien de l'activité
comment est-ce qu'on accompagne un pays
dans la difficulté mais on peut pas
traiter les pays de la zone euro on a vu
ce qui s'est passé en grèce
moi j'ai pas envie que le prochain pays
qui seront en difficulté soit traitée
comme la grèce l'a été jeudi compris
parce que quand même un des grands
atouts de l'union européenne c'est la
question démocratique
or les conditions d'intervention du fmi
s'ils ont mis un pays sous tutelle
ouais aujourd'hui justement c'est ça
allait être ma question suivante est ce
que concrètement on pourrait on pourrait
se retrouver comme en 2010 au début des
années 2010 avec la grèce au bord du
gouffre un chômage qui explose un pib
qui chute de 25% ou alors aujourd'hui la
zone euro a les outils nécessaires même
si ce n'est pas suffisant comprend bien
avec ce que vous dites mais a les outils
nécessaires pour faire face à une telle
situation par exemple parce qu'on est à
l'abri d'une telle situation aujourd'hui
au jeu
une crise arrive il ya des petits
indices mais on ne sait jamais où elle
va exploser parce que j'espère
qu'aujourd'hui on est peut-être à l'aune
d'une nouvelle crise qu'on ne va pas
venir ou qu'on ne veut pas voir venir
mais c'est peut-être aussi pour faire
pour empêcher que ça arrive d'être non
mais si elle arrivait j'espère que vous
serez mieux équipés que nous l'avons été
on s'assure sur la fission est ce qu on
peut être sûr en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est qu'on a fait beaucoup de choses
mais qu'on aurait pu faire mieux
plus vite plus fort et que quand vous
parlez de la fenêtre d'opportunité qui
est devant nous c'est ça avec ce risque
qui est que comme les indices tout le
monde ne le vis pas dans son quotidien
mais ce que disent les chiffres c'est
que la situation en termes de croissance
chômage
c'est un petit peu améliorée que du coup
on relâche la pression sur la nécessité
de doter cette zone euro de tous les
outils et ça c'est un grand risque
puisque ça va mieux on s'occupe pas de
réparer les fuites du toit puisque le
toit fuit un petit peu un petit peu
moins il faut éviter ça à tout prix
finalement on parle on parle de projets
à moyen long terme
on sait que je voyais à long terme c'est
des processus très compliqué au sein du
sur le sur le vieux continent
tout ça est finalement une question de
de fédéralisme vouloir céder plus de
compétences nationales pour plus
d'europe partager voilà de compétence
vous préférez ce terme là c'est pas
encore très tendance malgré l'arrivée
d'emmanuel mâcon au pouvoir en europe
est ce que vous pensez concrètement que
ça va ce faire ces projets là savait
regardez dans le domaine fiscal
on avance à tout petits pas est d'autant
plus qu'on est dans un domaine où les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement font les
ministres décident à l'unanimité
et pourtant parce qu'il ya une pression
parce que les gens les gens sont très
intelligents et une beauté ils sentent
les choses
alors parfois il n'apporte pas les
bonnes réponses l'on voit les l'idée que
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale est
une priorité absolue c'est quelque chose
qui sait je crois imposé au cours de ce
mandat et sur lequel on a quand même
fait des progrès là où pensez qu'il ya
quelques années ça serait très difficile
donc l'essentiel c'est de définir le cap
de le tenir et de franchir papa tout les
états et ce cap semble donc se décider
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
le salon de l'agriculture se tiendra du
24 février au 4 mars à la porte de
versailles à paris bien sûr quelle est
la place de l'agriculture en europe
exploitation production ont fait le
point avec olivier jeunes l'ex
responsable du centre europe direct à
saint germain en laye
[Musique]
on
en europe le pays qui a le moins
d'exploitations agricoles c'est le
luxembourg avec 2080 exploitations
agricoles sur l'ensemble de son
territoire est le pays qui a le plus
d'exploitations agricoles c'est la
roumanie avec alors 3 millions 629 1660
exploitations agricoles pour donner un
ordre d'idée la france elle à 472 1210
exploitations agricoles on constate deux
phénomènes sur l'évolution des
exploitations agricoles premièrement une
diminution du nombre d'exploitations
agricoles qui tourne aux alentours de 5
à 10% par rapport au début des années
2000 on a moins de très petites et
moyennes exploitations agricoles en
terme de surface par contre on constate
que le nombre d'hommes d'exploitations
agricoles qui ont un plus grand terrain
lui se maintient voire parfois se
développe dans certains pays on a
certains agriculteurs qui ont considéré
que entretenir que maintenir des petites
parcelles d'exploitation n'était pas
forcément viable pour eux et ont donc
décidé on va dire de mutualiser avec
d'autres exploitations agricoles afin de
faire les plus grandes surfaces qui
peuvent être plus rentable concernant
les spécificités des productions
agricoles
si on prend par exemple les pays qui
produisent le plus de serial bain les
pays concernés ce sont la pologne et
l'espagne
si on prend les pays qui produisent le
plus de
la boisson alcoolisée pour tout ce qui
est vins spiritueux et ainsi de suite et
bien évidemment l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé
on a notamment la france l'espagne et
l'italie et par exemple pour les pays
qui produisent le plus de lait là on à
l'allemagne la france et le royaume uni
l'agriculture biologique a tendance à se
développer au niveau européen 6 7% des
terres agricoles sont consacrées à
l'agriculture biologique
donc ça c'est la moyenne sur l'ensemble
des 28 pays de l'union européenne le
pays qui a le plus de surfaces agricoles
dédiées au biologique et l'autriche avec
21 2 % de son territoire tandis que le
pays qui a le plus qui a la plus petite
surface réservée à l'agriculture
biologique c'est malte avec 0 21% 2 102
08 21 % de ces terres agricoles la
france elle elle est un peu en dessous
de la moyenne européenne avec 5 3 % de
son territoire agricole qui est dédié à
l'agriculture biologique et pour
comparer avec notre voisin allemand
l'allemagne qui elle est à 6 8%
[Musique]
très rapidement puisqu'on sait que le
temps le temps nous guette tout de même
une réforme de la pac est elle aussi une
priorité aujourd'hui pour l'europe c'est
pas forcément votre sujet de
prédilection mais vous avez un point de
vue là-dessus forcément en tant
qu'européens convaincu est ce que la pac
c'est un sujet aussi qu'il faut dont il
faut se saisir rapidement
bien sûr et c'est un sujet sur lequel
les socialistes ont des propositions
très allante
pour preuve on peut pas avoir l'une des
principales politiques de l'union qui
soit pas totalement conformes avec nos
objectifs par ailleurs et comme la
question du développement durable c'est
une pac plus écologiques clé verte si
elle et puis enfin qu'il soit
respectueuse de la diversité biologique
de la nature et qui permettent en même
temps de nourrir dans des bonnes
conditions
les habitants ce qui veut dire moins de
glyphosate très fortement sur le sujet
mais moins de gm - de gm mais après des
résultats il faut au delà des paroles on
a vu aussi par exemple quand même au
sein du gouvernement sur la question des
glyphes du dif hosatte des distances sur
les ministres si le président on pouvait
mettre un peu d'ordre là-dedans pour ce
soit cohérent avec une approche
d'agriculture durable ce serait superbe
dernière modules de cette émission la
question d'un politique et pas n'importe
lequel qui vous interpellent en qualité
d'eurodéputés sur la problématique de
son choix
je vous propose d'écouter vous allez le
voir c'est finalement en lien avec notre
discussion passé à les écrits qui la
question qui se pose c'est le rapport
entre le parlement européen et les
parlements nationaux et la question ce
qu'on appelle un terme un peu techno la
subsidiarité
je crois que nous avons besoin les uns
des autres et notamment pour faire mieux
comprendre les enjeux de l'europe
à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens qui sont
souvent des tas d'interrogations et de
doutes
et la question que je pose à mes
collègues c'est comment bien faire
fonctionner ce dialogue entre les
parlements nationaux de l'union
européenne et le parlement européen
pardon je verrai c'est donc le président
du sénat ancien maire de rambouillet qui
vous pose cette question tout est en
lien avec les yvelines que lui répondez
vous à cette interrogation sur ce lien
entre parlement national nationaux et
puis parlement européen comment on
favorise le lien se situe à gérard
larcher qui l'a absolument réseau chacun
doit faire son travail à son niveau mais
la subsidiarité c'est un terme qui
marche dans les deux sens ça suppose
qu'au plan national les parlement puisse
vraiment interpellé leur gouvernement
quant aux positions qu'ils prennent et
qu'ils défendent au conseil les soutenir
ou les critiquer lorsque ceux ci ne leur
convient pas et qu à l inverse on puisse
prendre au niveau européen les questions
qui s'imposent au nom de domaine de la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
il faut que chaque administration ait
les moyens de bien regarder ce qui se
passe est de comprendre ce qui se passe
mais s'il n'y a pas de coopération entre
les administrations fiscales
c'est du pain béni pour tous les
fraudeurs et ceux qui cherchent à y va d
assez bas des du fisc donc on a vraiment
besoin d'une bonne compréhension est ce
que vous par exemple vous vous discutez
vous avez des liens fréquents avec les
députés français qui sont de votre bord
politique puis les autres aussi
évidemment est-ce que vous avez un lien
assez important avec eux aussi souvent
que possible c'est jamais très facile à
une nouvelle gauche a maintenant c'est
comme ça c'est le nouveau nom à la
solution avait d'ailleurs certains de
mes collègues sont sont ici au parlement
européen ce matin pour parler
migration donc il ya des liens qu'il ya
des liens qui existent vous savez la
difficulté vous la connaissez c'est que
le coeur de la semaine pour l'activité
parlementaire c'est le mardi mercredi
jeudi et ce sont les jours où chacun est
mobilisé dans son assemblée mais c'est
tout à fait essentiel de le faire le
plus souvent possible
merci pervenche berès d'avoir participé
à ce site 8 europe le rappelle que vous
êtes eurodéputés évidemment socialiste
d'île de france membre notamment de la
commission des affaires économiques et
monétaires ici au parlement
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
replay sur notre site internet
il a commenté aussi sur nos réseaux
sociaux tv 78 la semaine prochaine vous
retrouver le 7-8 politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à